[Music]
20 years ago if children wanted to
become famous their parents would have
to invest in singing lessons or drive
them to castings now thanks to the
Internet children are becoming famous
without even trying if you're a
first-time viewer click the red
subscribe button to see more videos like
this today we're discussing 10 people
who were trending before they turned 14
Zooey Raw when Zooey Rock was just 4
years old her father stopped a now
infamous photo of her in front of a
house that was up in flames four years
later she would become known to the
Internet as disaster girl thankfully
when her photo went viral in 2008 it was
still a time when viral photos didn't
get as much recognition as they do now
so she was able to have a normal
childhood the now teenager loves the
fact that she is disaster girl though
she claims she isn't too good at
starting fires like her famous meme
would suggest Jonathan where Jonathan
ware was only 10 years old when his
three-word response to her a reporter
gained him 53 million YouTube views
where became an internet sensation in
2007 for his reply of I like turtles
to an unrelated question from a news
reporter now nearly a decade later the
20 year old has started his own YouTube
channel so it's difficult to recognize
him without all his zombie makeup
rebeccablack
in 2011 Rebecca black became an internet
sensation but for all the wrong reasons
the 13 year olds parents thought it
would be a fun treat for their daughter
to record a music video for a song she
wrote called Friday when she uploaded it
to YouTube she had no idea that her life
would change forever though the music
video initially sat virtually unmute for
a couple of months it didn't take long
for it to become viral the problem is
what black thought was going to be her
big break turned out to be considered
one of the worst songs in history
Charlie and Harry davies-carr the
internet fell in love with brothers
Charlie and Harry Davies car when their
home video went viral on YouTube in 2007
the video shows three-year-old Harry
playing with his baby brother Charlie
who bites his finger and the rest is
internet history since it was uploaded
in 2007 the video has over 800 million
views and their parents have made
thousands of dollars thanks to
advertising and sponsors though their
internet stars because of the 56 second
clip the boy
still think it's strange that so many
people have watched the video Sophia
Grace Sophia Grace was ready for a music
career when she was just eight years old
so when her family uploaded her and her
cousin singing Nicki Minaj's Super Bass
the Internet was quick to fall in love
Grace and her cousin even appeared on
The Ellen DeGeneres Show where they got
to meet their idol Nicki Minaj Sophia
hasn't slowed down since her viral debut
the mountain ager has started her music
career and even released a music video
in January 2017 that already has over 6
million views on YouTube David Devore
jr. David after the Dennis was the
second most viewed YouTube video in 2009
the star of the video was a drugged up 7
year old named David Devore jr. David's
father recorded his seven-year-old son
after a visit to the dentist left him
questioning reality the video was viewed
over 3 million times in 3 days and made
little David and internet sensation his
father was even able to quit his job as
a Realtor and made a hundred and fifty
thousand dollars from the video within a
year of posting it Samy Greiner everyone
has seen the infamous success baby meme
but what you may not know is that the
baby Sammy Greiner was actually just
eating sand his mother had no idea that
her son would become internet history
when she uploaded the photo in 2007
luckily for her husband Sammy was able
to use his internet stardom in 2015 to
help his father raise money for a kidney
transplant the family successfully
raised over $100,000 thanks to Sammy's
internet fame and his father was able to
go through with his kidney transplant
Noah Ritter in August of 2014 Noah
Ritter became the internet's beloved
apparently boy
the toddler won the hearts of millions
because of his love for the word
apparently that he used over and over in
an interview that went viral where Ellen
DeGeneres fell for his charming
interview skills DeGeneres sent the
five-year-old to a dinosaur exhibit as
part of a hilarious segment which earned
him reoccurring spots on her hit daytime
talk show Jessica Chatfield Jessica
Chatfield had all the makings of a child
star when her Jessica's daily
affirmations video went viral in 2010
she was shown as an adorable
four-year-old who could moonlight
the motivational speaker but there was
one small issue the video was actually
reported in 2001 and Jessica was
actually 12 when the video went viral
though the internet was upset that the
little girl in the video was older it
didn't stop her from appearing on Comedy
Central's tosh.0
Danielle bar goalie 13-year old Danielle
/ goalie has shot to internet stardom
thanks to her now infamous appearance on
the dr. Phil show the teens mother went
to dr. Phil for help because Danielle
was stealing credit cards and had run
away from home for time but when the
team became annoyed with audience
members
she threatened them to cash me outside
how about that the trouble team now has
millions of followers on social media
and is pretty much taking over the
Internet what do you think of these
people who were trending before they
turned 14 react in the comments section
below and to see more of your favorite
viral stars check out our friends at the
taco who make videos about everything
from fitness to random occurrences in 5
minutes or less
[Music]